à chaque lundi du mois de février à
l'occasion de la saison des réels on va
consacrer une portion de l'émission à
vos finances personnelles à vos
préoccupations avec un expert on va
notamment répondre à vos questions et
c'est samedi le chapelle qu'on a le
plaisir d'amorter avec qui on a le
plaisir d'amorcer cette série de février
les planificatrices financières
indépendantes bonsoir madame Lachapelle
bonsoir donc officiellement on appelle
ça la saison des rivières le mois des
réels est-ce que on devrait appeler ça
comme ça ou est-ce qu'au contraire c'est
le mois des retardataires si on veut
mais certaines personnes pourraient
mériter le chapeau de retardateur je
pense entre autres aux gens qui sont
salariés qui ont revenu fixe un emploi
stable donc qui ont la possibilité
d'avoir un plan d'investissement un plan
de planification de la retraite qui est
régulier donc parallèlement ça il y a
d'autres personnes pour qui c'est que ça
s'explique peut-être un peu cet
argument-là du réel en début d'année je
pense notamment au travers autonome qui
ont à consolidé avec une gestion des
liquidités un peu plus complexe parfois
les chefs d'entreprise qui attend des
résultats de fin d'année pour ajouter
leur rémunération il y a des employés
cliques qui peuvent recevoir des bonnets
et les verser au réa donc c'est normal
qu'en début d'année il y a un engouement
pour le réel mais effectivement
certaines personnes sont retardataires
et ce qu'on oublie souvent ce que le
réel en réalité c'est un portefeuille
d'investissement c'est un placement
c'est un pardon c'est un portefeuille de
placement qu'on doit traiter comme
n'importe quel portefeuille donc on doit
investir régulièrement c'est une des
clés de la réussite en matière de
gestion portefeuille c'est d'investir le
marché régulièrement pour se prémunir de
la volatilité et aussi avoir la
discipline d'épargne donc ça nous évite
de dépenser l'argent ailleurs également
plutôt que de le faire donc à la
dernière minute en février avant
l'échéance et on le rappelle l'échéance
donc 1er mars plusieurs téléspectateurs
nous ont fait parvenir des questions sur
les finances personnelles on va regarder
quelques-unes ensemble d'abord celle
d'Hélène réel de percer qui nous demande
ceci qu'arrive-t-il si on se trompe et
qu'on dépense le maximum des cotisations
permise pour les réels et les séries
quelles sont conséquences Madame La
Chapelle deux niveaux mais premièrement
au niveau financier il y a des pénalités
donc si vous dépassez vos droits de
cotisations réelles il y a une impôt
spéciale 1% sur l'excédent de 2000
dollars par rapport au montant de que
vous avez versé en trop évidemment si
vous pouvez retirer là des enregistrer
la cotisation dans le même mois vous ne
serez pas affecté par cette impôts là
mais si vous avez dépassé le délai vous
devrez compléter un formulaire qui est
le TA ou VP vous le votre trait ensuite
devrait être imposable vous devrez
demander une déduction qu'on pense à toi
avec le formulaire T30 12a donc voilà
c'est un peu compliqué pour le sili
c'est la même pénalité d'un pour cent et
pour spécial donc sur le sol de plus
élevé pendant le mois pour chaque mois
que vous dépassez vos votre droit de
cotisation Celli il y a pas de
formulaire par contre vous pouvez
seulement faire le retrait corriger la
situation pour pour rétablir le tout
mais au-delà de tout ça le vire la
véritable pénalité là c'est la perte de
jouissance et de temps pas tout régler
ces éléments là donc j'invite vraiment
les gens à faire à utiliser le principe
de précaution ici on vérifie nos droits
inutilisés sur notre dossier en ligne à
l'agence de revenus du Canada avant
toute cotisation tout nouveau faire
attention avec les nombreux petits
montants d'investissement retraits ça
peut des fois nous jouer des tours très
bien on est prudent donc et on vérifie
d'abord question d'André DM maintenant
qui nous disent j'ai 65 ans et je reçois
une rampe de retraite par contre je
fonge a commencé à décaisser mon réel et
mon Celli par lequel devrais-je
commencer et à quel rythme
par rapport à l'ordre de décaissement
c'est sûr que on peut penser que ce
monsieur a déjà des revenus imposables
avec son régime de retraite qui serait
plus pertinent de retirer du sili avant
L'Oréal pour limiter son imposition
quand monsieur dit qu'ils songe à
retirer mais le faut se demander est-ce
que c'est qu'il y en a besoin donc c'est
véritablement la question derrière
chaque plante décaissement donc on
arrive à la retraite on se fait un plan
sur nos besoins personnel donc ils
peuvent varier d'une personne à l'autre
la solution peut aussi varier c'est un
conjoint donc c'est un autre
contribuable ou même à la même adresse
que nous donc cet exercice là à faire et
dans le cas de Monsieur aussi plus qu'un
régime de retraite il y a même lieu de
faire une analyse à savoir est-ce que
dépendamment des besoins ce serait même
pas plus pertinent de repousser par
exemple à riche des rentes du Québec la
prestation de la Sécurité de la
vieillesse donc vous voyez ça semble
très simple mais il y a beaucoup de
facteurs personnels individuels à
considérer ça nécessite donc quelques
calculs question de Louise Lafont de
Baie-Comeau qui dit mon conseiller me
semble vouloir se tenir au moins des
fonds de travailleurs comme ceux de la
FTQ ou de la CSN ne sont-ils pas
avantageux pourtant du point de vue
fiscal à court terme c'est indéniable
c'est un très institutif d'avoir un
crédit d'impôt de l'ordre de jusqu'à 30%
simplement garder en tête que d'autres
éléments à considérer donc je pense
notamment la flexibilité quand souscrit
ce type d'action là faut vraiment le
voir comme un investissement pour la
retraite à long terme ne serait-ce que
parce que les modalités de retrait sont
un petit peu moins souples et moins
flexible que d'autres véhicules
d'épargnent donc peut-être garder ça en
tête si vous pensez utiliser par exemple
le régime d'accession la propriété mais
c'est bon c'est c'est quand même
accessible sur un petit peu plus de
rigidité au niveau de la diversification
mais c'est la même chose donc c'est un
bon investissement mais c'est comme dans
tout on ne met pas nos œufs tous nos
œufs dans le même panier donc c'est
vraiment considéré comme un ensemble si
vous cotisez si vous achetez en fait des
actions pour 5000$ par année sur une
cotisation sur des investissements
totaux qui sont très importants un peu
significatif mais si ça représente 100 %
de votre épargne peut-être qu'au niveau
de la diversification il y a un exercice
à regarder très bien il nous reste à
peine 30 secondes est-ce qu'on a le
temps de répondre à la question qui nous
est fréquemment posé hausse des taux
d'intérêt est-ce que je mets de l'argent
dans mon réel ou je rembourse mon
hypothèque je vous réponds que c'est un
faux dilemme est-ce qu'on devrait
rembourser notre hypothèque en accéléré
avec la hausse des taux absolument
est-ce qu'on doit le faire au coût de
couper dans l'épargne de la retraite
avec le réel probablement pas donc la
vraie question c'est peut-être est-ce
que il y a des dépenses discrétionnaires
que je peux diminuer ou éliminer de mon
budget pour accélérer le remboursement
de l'hypothèque donc la vraie question
c'est est-ce que je vais aller dans le
sud cette année est-ce que je vais
changer mon vélo de montagne ou ma
voiture ils n'ont pas est-ce que je vais
faire du réel ou remboursement de beauté
ça c'est une des préoccupations qui nous
est souligné très rapidement très
souvent en fait étant donné à hausse
rapide des taux d'intérêt qui met de la
pression sur le budget mensuel des
ménages très bien Madame la chapelle
c'est un premier rendez-vous on vous
retrouvera effectivement au mois de
février merci d'avoir été là
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]